différents et nous insisterons pour
lutter contre ce qui promeut font la
promotion du conflit et non pas ceux qui
recherchent la paix la prospérité dans
ce cycle de suspicion et de discorde et
bien ceci que doit prendre fin
je suis venu ici au caire pour commencer
un nouveau chemin entre les etats-unis
et le monde musulman
un chemin qui soit fondé sur des
intérêts mutuels et le respect mutuel un
chemin qui soit fondé sur la volonté la
compo conviction que les états unis et
le monde musulman ne sont pas exclusifs
l'un de l'autre mais au contraire
partagent des principes communs des
principes de justice de progrès de
tolérance et de dignité de l'ensemble
des êtres humains
je le faisais je fais en reconnaissant
que le changement ne pourra pas
intervenir du jour au lendemain
alors là beaucoup parlé de mon discours
mais un discours ne peut pas éradiquer
des années de méfiance ou de défiance
pas plus que dans le temps qui m'est
imparti cet après midi je ne saurais
répondre à l'ensemble des questions
complexes sur le sujet mais je suis
convaincu que pour avancer
nous devons dire ouvertement les uns aux
autres les choses que nous avons sur le
coeur choses qui bien souvent ne sont
dit que derrière des portes closes
nous devons entreprendre un effort
soutenu pour nous écouter les uns des
autres les uns les autres pour nous
apprendre les uns des autres pour nous
respecter mutuellement et pour trouver
des points de convergence comme le coran
je le dis soyons conscients de dieu et
disons toujours la vérité
c'est exactement ce que je serai de
faire aujourd'hui de dire la vérité du
mieux possible
humble face à la tâche qui nous attend
et ferme dans ma conviction que
l'intérêt que nous partageons en tant
qu'être humain est bien supérieur aux
forces qui nous sépare cette conviction
je la tiens de ma propre expérience en
partie je suis chrétien mais mon père
venait d'une famille kényane et la
génération de musulmans
j'ai passé des années mon enfance en
indonésie et j'ai entendu l'appel du
azan à l'aube et au crépuscule et en
tant que jeune j'ai travaillé dans des
communautés à chicago où beaucoup ont
trouvé la dignité et la paix dans leur
foi musulmane
je connais puisque j'ai étudié
l'histoire la dette de la civilisation
vers l'islam c'est l'islam qui dans des
lieux comme al azhar ont transmis le
savoir pendant des siècles et des
siècles apportant la lumière et la
renaissance à l'europe c'est la rénover
la rénovation des deux communautés
musulmanes
c'est l'innovation de 1000 communautés
musulmanes qui ont développé l'algèbre
le la boussole ou les instruments de
navigation qui ont compris comment les
maladies se propagent et comment elle
pourrait être dès que pouvait être
soigné nous a donc inspiré nous a
beaucoup apporté musique la calligraphie
et des endroits de contemplation
pacifique et à travers l'histoire
l'islam a démontré par les faits et par
les mots les possibilités de tolérance
religieuse et d'égalité raciale
c'est aussi que l'islam toujours fait
partie de l'histoire américaine
la première nation à reconnaître mon
pays a été le maroc signant le traité de
tripoli en 1796 notre deuxième président
de dams a écrit que les états unis
n'avaient en soit aucune animosité
contre les lois la religion la
tranquillité des musulmans et depuis
notre fondation les fonds des musulmans
américains ont enrichi les états unis
ils ont lutté dans nos guerres ayant
servi dans nos gouvernements ils sont
battus pour les droits civiques ils ont
lancé des entreprises ils ont enseigné
est ancré a pris dans nos universités
ils ont fait du sport dans nos stades
ils ont construit et ils ont même porter
la torche olympique le premier musulman
américain a été élu au congrès il a
prêté serment
un autre constitution sur le même coran
que thomas jefferson de nos pères
fondateurs avait dans sa bibliothèque
personnelle
donc je connais l'islam avant de venir à
la régie dans la région où il est apparu
et cette expérience guide ma conviction
selon laquelle le partenariat entre
l'amérique et l'islam doit se fonder sur
ce qu'ils lisent à bhl et non pas sur ce
qu'il n'est pas et je considère comme
une de mes responsabilités en tant que
président des états unis de lutter
contre les stéréotypes négatifs de
l'islam là où ils sont
mais ce même principe doit s'appliquer
également aux perceptions musulmane de
l'amérique
c'est la même manière que les musulmans
ne répondent pas à un stéréotype unique
l'amérique n'est pas un stéréotype d'un
tel empire uniquement intéressé par soi
même
les etats-unis ont été l'une des sources
de progrès les plus importantes que le
monde ait jamais connu une somme nés
d'une révolution contre un empire
nous avons fondé notre pays sur l'idée
que tous sont égaux et nous avons lutté
par notre sens pendant des siècles pour
donner du sens à ces mots quand nos
frontières et à l'extérieur dans le
monde entier nous sommes façonnés par
d'innombrables culture venant du monde
entier et orienté vers un concept unique
de beaucoup un seul je suis un
afro-américain appelé barack hussein
obama peut être élu président des états
unis
mais mon histoire personnelle n'est pas
si unique
le rêve de d'opportunités pour tous
n'est pas vrai pour tous en amérique
mais cette promesse existe pour tous
ceux qui viennent ce qui implique de 7
millions musulmans américains qui dans
notre pays aujourd'hui
de fait il ya une davantage que la
moyenne américaine
de plus la liberté en amérique et
indivisible de la liberté de culte
c'est pour cela qu'il ya des mosquées
dans chacun de nos états protégeons par
exemple le droit des filles et des
femmes à porter le voile et nous
punissions ce qu'il renoue ce droit donc
il ne fait aucun doute
l'islam fait partie de l'amérique et je
suis convaincu que l'amérique en son
sein je partage cette idée que tous
indépendamment en religion la race vise
les mêmes objectifs la paix la sécurité
un travail une éducation la possibilité
d'aimer leurs familles leurs communautés
leur dieu
voilà autant d'éléments que nous
partageons et senna l'espoir de
l'ensemble de l'humanité
bien sûr reconnaître notre humanité
commune n'est que le début de notre
travail
les mots seuls ne peuvent pas répondre
aux besoins des peuples ses besoins
seront répondu que si nous travaillons
efficacement dans l'est
les années à venir et si nous comprenons
que nos défis son conjoint et si nous
répondons pas à ces défis nous en
souffrons tous nous avons appris des
expériences récentes que lorsqu'un
système financier s'affaiblit dans un
pays la prospérité en soufre partout
lorsqu'une nouvelle à nouveau virus de
la grippe touche un être humain c'est
l'ensemble des êtres humains qui sont en
danger
lorsqu'une nation se dote de l'arme
nucléaire le risque d'akkad attaque
nucléaire plane sur touche lorsque les
théories se réfugient dans des montagnes
c'est le monde entier qui sont en quête
en danger
voilà ce que veut dire partager le monde
en ce 21ème siècle c'est là la
responsabilité que nous avons les uns
envers les autres en tant qu'être humain
et c'est une responsabilité difficile à
assumer
car l'histoire de l'humanité regorge
d'exemples de nation de tribus et oui de
religion également qui se subjugue les
unes les autres dans la quête de leur
propre intérêt mais dans cette nouvelle
ère
ces types d'attitudes sont vouées à
l'échec
étant donné notre interdépendance chaque
pan du monde qui érige un peuple au
dessus d'un autre échouera
inévitablement nous devons tirer les
leçons du passé sans en être prisonniers
nous avons appris à être des partenaires
nos progrès doivent être partagés
non jamais ceci ne veut pas dire que
nous devons ignorer les éléments de
tension et de fait ça veut dire linverse
nous devons faire face frontalement à
ces tensions
et dans cet esprit permettez-moi d'être
si claire et explicite que possible sur
certains points spécifiques dont je
crois nous devrons aborder et nous
convenait attaquer ensemble
premier point l'extrémisme violent sous
toutes ses formes
j'ai dit clairement ankara que
l'amérique ne seraient jamais en guerre
avec l'islam
et pourtant lutterons sans cesse contre
l'extrémisme violent qui représente une
menace importante contre notre contre
nos peuples
car tout le monde rejette l'assassinât
d'innocents de femmes et d'hommes et
d'enfants innocents et mon premier
devoir en tant que président c'est de
protéger le peuple américain
la situation en afghanistan tu démontres
les objectifs de l'amérique et notre
besoin de travailler ensemble
il vient septembre les états unis ont
poursuivi al qaïda et les talibans avec
l'aide de la communauté internationale
nous n'y sommes pas allés par choix nous
y sommes allés par besoin par nécessité
et je suis conscient qu'il reste encore
des gens pour se poser la question ou
voir même justifier leur septembre mais
soyons clairs al-qaïda a tué près de 3 6
3 mille personnes ce jour là les
victimes étaient des hommes des femmes
des enfants innocents d'amérique mais
aussi d'autres nations qui n'avait rien
fait qu'ils avaient nui à personne et
pourtant al qaïda a choisi d'assassiner
ces gens là
revendiquant l'attaqué et rieuse
revendiquant même aujourd'hui leur
détermination à tuer à grande échelle
ce ne sont pas des opinions qui peuvent
se débattre ce sont des faits que nous
devons traiter et ne nous trompons pas
nous ne voulons pas maintenir nos
troupes en afghanistan
nous n'envisageons pas
implantation militaire durable là bas
mais nous voulons protéger les
américains c'est difficile c'est coûteux
politiquement et financièrement de
poursuivre ce conflit ne serions ravis
de pouvoir ramener toutes nos troupes à
la maison si nous pouvions être sûr
qu'il n'y ait pas de d'extrémistes
violents en afghanistan est désormais au
pakistan déterminés à tuer autant
d'américains qu'ils peuvent
ce n'est pas encore le cas et c'est pour
ça que nous travaillons avec une
coalition de 46 pays et malgré le coup
le l'engagement américain ne faiblira
pas car personne aucun d'entre nous
devrait tolérer ces extrémistes
ils ont tué leurs biens des pays ils ont
tué des gens de différentes confessions
mais par dessus tout ils ont tué des
musulmans actions sont inconciliables
avec le droit des êtres humains les
progrès des nations et avec l'islam
lui-même le coran nous apprend que
quiconque tue un innocent est
l'équivalent d'avoir tué l'ensemble de
l'humanité
et le coran dit également que quiconque
sauf une personne fait comme s'il avait
sauvé l'ensemble de l'humanité la fois
de plus un moyen de personnes et plus
tellement plus grande que la haine
étroite d'une poignée l'islam ce n'est
pas le une partie du problème de la
lutte contre l'extrémisme non c'est une
partie importante de la solution pour
lutter contre les extrémistes et nous
savons bien entendu que les les aspects
militaires ne résoudrons pas tous les
problèmes en irak en afghanistan et
c'est pour ça que nous allons dévoue 5
milliards de dollars chaque année
pendant les cinq premières années
prochaines années pour construire des
écoles
on a bien dit ce temps et pour aider
tous ceux qui ont été déplacés c'est
pour ça que nous donnons plus de 2,8
milliards de dollars pour aider les
afghans à développer leur économie et
pourrait importer des services sur
lesquels les gens dépend et permettez
moi également de revenir sur la question
de l'irak
à l'inversé de l'afghanistan l'irak a
fait l'objet d'un choix défendu
fermement dans mon pays dans le monde
entier et même si je crois que le peuple
irakien est mieux loti sans la tyrannie
de saddam hussein je crois également que
les événements irakien rappelé
eric à l'amérique le besoin d'utiliser
la diplomatie le consensus pour résoudre
nos problèmes lorsque cela est possible
rappelons-nous les mots de thomas
steffen qui a dit j'espère que notre
sagesse va grandir en même temps que
notre pouvoir moi nous utilisons la
force plus important elle sera
aujourd'hui l'amérique a une double
responsabilité d'aider l'irak à forger
un avenir meilleur et de redonner l'irak
aux irakiens
j'ai dit très clairement au peuple
irakien j'ai dit très clairement au
peuple irakien que nous ne cherchons pas
à nous installer que nous n'avons aucune
prétention
concernant l'irak
l'irak est un pays souverain c'est la
raison pour laquelle je demandais que
certaines de nos brigades son navire à
quai dès le mois d'août
nous allons tenir notre engagement les
troupes dans les villes irakiennes
partiront d'ici au mois de juillet et
toutes les troupes seront partis en 2012
nous allons aider l'irak à former ses
forces de sécurité et à développer son
économie mais nous voulons que l'irak
soit un partenaire et nous ne voulons
pas regardez l'irak de haut nous ne
pouvons pas tolérer la violence des
extrémistes mais nous ne pouvons pas
également oublier nos principes 11
septembre suppose un traumatisme
terrible pour notre pays
la peur l'angoissé que cela crée dans
tout à fait compréhensible mais parfois
cela nous a amené aller à l'encontre de
nos traditions et de nos idéaux et
maintenant nous prenons des actions très
concrètes pour nous remettre sur le
droit chemin
j'ai interdit l'utilisation des de la
torture et je veux la fermeture de la
prison de guantanamo avant la fin de
l'année proche l'année prochaine
l'amérique
bien sûr se défendra en respectant la
souveraineté des nations et l'état de
droit et nous le ferons en partenariat
avec les communautés musulmanes qui sent
menacée plus rapidement nous arriverons
à isoler les extrémistes et plus
rapidement nous serons tous en sécurité
la deuxième source majeure de tension
dont nous devons discuter et la
situation entre les israéliens les
palestiniens et le monde arabe
les liens très forts entre l'amérique et
israël sont bien connus
ces liens ne seront jamais briser ils
sont fondés sur des liens historiques
politiques sur la reconnaissance du fait
que le droit au peuple d'israël de
disposer d'une terre c'est suite à une
persécution
pendant des siècles les lentilles
l'antisémitisme en europe a provoqué un
holocauste terrible demain je me rendrai
à buchan valdes un camp dans lequel les
juifs ont été emprisonnés torturés gaz
est tué par le troisième reich
six millions de juifs ont été tués plus
que la population
il serait line aujourd'hui nier cela
c'est ridicule c'est sans fondement
historique menacer israël de destruction
ou répéter des stéréotypes stupide et
négatifs sur l les juifs ne sert à rien
cela ne fait
qu'empêcher la paix à laquelle ont droit
les peuples de cette région
d'autre part il est également impossible
de nier que le peuple palestinien
composé de chrétiens de musulmans a
souffert dans sa quête de terres pendant
plus de 60 ans les palestiniens ont
souffert de leur déplacement beaucoup
qui vivent dans les camps de réfugiés en
cisjordanie ou à gaza à la tante de la
paix de la sécurité qui n'ont jamais
plus pu atteindre vivent au quotidien
l'humiliation que suppose l'occupation
donc il n'y a aucun doute sur le fait
que la situation pour le peuple
palestinien est une situation
intolérable
les etats-unis ne vont pas tourner leur
dos aux aspirations naturel et légitime
du peuple palestinien à obtenir une
terre
project x dame de fer pendant des
décennies des peuples avec des
aspirations légitimes chacun avec une
histoire difficile et douloureuse ne
sont pas parvenus au compromis
il est facile de pointer du doigt de la
part des palestiniens pointé du doigt à
la création de l'état d'israël et
ensuite de l'autre côté les attaques qui
sont faites à israël et aux juifs
ailleurs mais si l'on regarde les choses
d'un seul côté
alors nous verrons jamais la vérité la
seule résolution c'est de prendre en
compte la situation des deux peuples
avec la création de deux états qui
puisse vivre en paix et en sécurité
et cela est dans l'intérêt d'israël dans
l'intérêt de la palestine dans l'intérêt
des états unis d'amérique dans l'intérêt
du monde entier et c'est la raison pour
laquelle je vais personnellement essayé
de faire avancer cet objectif avec toute
la patience et l'engagement que fait
tâche implique les obligations sur
lesquels les deux parties se sont mises
d'accord c'est la feuille de route cette
feuille de route est claire pour
parvenir à la paix il est donc grand
temps pour eux pour nous tous de revenir
de voir quels sont nos responsabilités
la résistance par la violence et la
tuerie mène nulle part pendant deux
siècles les noirs américains ont
souffert de l'humiliation de la
ségrégation des coups de fouets de leurs
maîtres
mais ce n'est pas par la violence qu'on
a atteint les droits c'est par une
insistance
après rama nantes en rappelant qu'elle
était les idéaux des pères fondateurs et
cette histoire c'est presque là même qui
est racontée en afrique du sud en asie
du sud-est en europe c'est la même
histoire avec une vérité simple
la violence ne mène nulle part la
violence n'est pas un signe de courage
n'est pas un signe de force envoyé des
bombes sur des enfants faire sauter une
femme dans un bus
ce n'est pas de cette manière qu'on
réclame l'autorité morale c'est de la
lâcheté grand temps pour les
palestiniens de se concentrer sur ce
qu'ils peuvent construire l'autorité
palestinienne doit renforcer sa capacité
de gouvernement en créant des
institutions qui soit au service de son
peuple
le hamas bien sûr à l'appui de certains
palestiniens mais il faut reconnaître
qu'elle est la responsabilité du
également jouer le rôle qui doit être le
sien d'unifier le peuple palestinien et
de répondre aux aspirations du peuple
palestinien le hamas doit reconnaître
les accords passés et reconnaître le
droit d'israël à exister renoncer à la
violence et dans le même temps les
israéliens doivent reconnaître que tout
comme le droit d'israël à exister ne
peut être nié ce droit pour les
palestiniens ne peut être nié non plus
nous devons en finir avec la
colonisation israélienne
ces constructions violent les accords
passés et empêchent de parvenir à la
paix il est temps que cette colonisation
cesse israël doit se souvenir ses
obligations et assuré que les
palestiniens peuvent vivre travailler et
développer la société palestinienne
la crise humanitaire à gaza empêchent de
parvenir la sécurité en israël
la même chose en cisjordanie les
problèmes quotidiens des palestiniens
doivent être réglés et doivent être
sains un des points essentiels de la
paix et israël va devoir prendre des
mesures pour permettre de progresser sur
cette voie les états arabes pour finir
doivent reconnaître que l'initiative de
paix était un bon début mais ce n'est
pas la fin des responsabilités le
conflit israélo arabe ne doit pas être
utilisé pour détourner l'attention des
peuples arabes
il faut absolument aider les
palestiniens à développer leurs
institutions reconnaître la légitimité
d'israël
et essayer d'éviter les erreurs du passé
l'amérique côte à côte avec ceux qui
souhaitent la paix et nous allons dire
en public ce que nous disons en privé
que ce soit aux palestiniens et aux
israéliens ou aux arabes en général nous
ne pouvons pas imposer la paix en privé
beaucoup de musulmans disent qu' israël
ne va pas disparaître tout comme les
israéliens
beaucoup d'israéliens disent qu'il faut
un état palestinien
essayons maintenant d'agir par rapport à
la vérité trop de larmes ont été versées
trop de sang a coulé nous avons tous une
responsabilité travailler pour ce jour
où les mères palestiniennes et
israéliennes pourront voir leurs enfants
grandir sans père quand la terre sainte
des trois grandes religions monothéistes
sera enfin l'endroit que dieu a voulu un
endroit de paix quand les chrétiens les
juifs et les musulmans pourront jouer
ensemble comme le dit l'histoire
d'israël
quel de dix ans la terre d'abrams quand
dans l'histoire d'israël mais moïse et
jésus pour enfin se joindre dans la même
prière troisième source de tension
maintenant notre intérêt partagé
concernant les responsabilités des
nations quant à l'utilisation de l'armé
nucléaire
cette question est une source de tension
entre les états unis d'amérique et la
république islamique d'iran pendant
beaucoup d'années
l'iran a vécu en opposition à mon pays
au milieu de la guerre froide les états
unis ont renversé un gouvernement élu de
manière démocratique
l'iran a également agi contre les civils
et les troupes américaines
nous avons tous les auteurs mais plutôt
que de rester les yeux rivés sur le
passé j'ai dit très clairement au peuple
iranien et au leader iranien que nous
étions prêts à aller de l'avant
la question est maintenant n'est pas de
savoir ce contre quoi et l'iran mais ce
que veut construire les rangs je sais
qu'il sera très difficile d'en finir
avec des décennies de méfiance mais nous
sommes engagés à agir dignement et de
manière droite
nous voulons aller de l'avant sans
préalable sur la base du respect mutuel
il est clair pour tous que quand il
s'agit d'armes nucléaires nous avons
atteint un point décisif
il ne s'agit pas uniquement de l'intérêt
des états unis d'amérique
c'est pour éviter une course à
l'armement nucléaire au moyen-orient qui
pourraient men et mener cette région et
le monde entier sur un chemin beaucoup
trop dangereux
je comprends ceux qui protestent et qui
disent que certains disposent de césar
mais d'autres pas aucune nation seul
devrait choisir un qui doit avoir l'armé
nucléaire
c'est la raison pour laquelle je répète
que nous voulons une planète sans armes
nucléaires qu'aucune nation ne disposent
que l'ami club aucune nation et toutes
toutes les nations même l'iran peuvent
avoir accès au nucléaire civil
si ces pays signent le traité de non
prolifération nucléaire
c'est un élément essentiel le nucléaire
civil
au sein de ce traité et je suis
convaincu que nous partageons cet
objectif tous dans la région
quatrième point la démocratie
je sais il ya eu les au coût de
controverses concernant la promotion de
la démocratie
et cette controverse est liée à la
guerre en irak en irak
je vais être clair aucun système de
gouvernement où devrait être imposée par
une nation sur une autre cela ne réduit
pas mon engagement je veux des
gouvernements qui reflètent la volonté
du peuple
chaque pays essaye de faire cela on
prendra en compte sa culture
nous n'avons pas la prétention de savoir
ce qui est bon pour tous comme nous ne
pouvons pas prédire les résultats d'une
élection pacifique mais j'ai néanmoins
une croyance très enracinée sur le fait
que le peuple doit avoir la possibilité
de dire ce qu'il pense sur la manière
dont il est gouverné confiance en l'état
de droit une égalité de traitement par
la justice disposer d'un gouvernement
transparent qui ne volent pas à son
peuple la liberté de vivre comme on
entend ce ne sont pas des idéaux
américains
ce sont des droits de l'homme c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous allons les
appuyer
partout
pour tenir cette promesse
il n'y a pas de plan tout fait mais les
gouvernements qui protège ses droits
sont plus sûrs plus prospères essayé de
supprimer des idées ça ne la fait pas
disparaître
l'amérique respecte le droit de toutes
les voies pacifiques qui veulent se
faire entendre dans le monde même quand
nous ne sommes pas d'accord avec elle et
nous allons saluer tous les
gouvernements élus de manière pacifique
si ils gouvernent pacifiquement et
prennent en compte toutes leurs
populations c'est un élément important
car beaucoup en appellent à la
démocratie quand ils n'en sont pas au
pouvoir mais quand ils sont au pouvoir
ils essayent de supprimer le droit
d'autres
il faut un gouvernement par le peuple et
pour le peuple
ça devrait être la norme
pour ceux qui ont le pouvoir il faut
maintenir se maintenir au pouvoir par le
biais du consensus et pas de la menace
il faut respecter les droits des
minorités et participer dans un esprit
de tolérance et des compromis au
dialogue il faut placer l'intérêt des
peuples au dessus de son parti ou de ses
envies personnelles
sans cela il n'y a pas de démocratie
réelle
la troisième question que nous devons
relever ensemble la cinquième question
morale c'est la question de la foi
l'islam a une grande tradition de
tolérance
nous l'avons vu dans l'histoire
d'andalousie ou de cordoue pendant
l'inquisition et en tant qu'enfant en
indonésie j'ai vu que les chrétiens
pouvaient célébrer leur culte librement
dans un pays majoritairement musulman
voilà l'esprit dont nous avons besoin
aujourd'hui les gens dans tous les pays
devraient être libres de pouvoir choisir
leur leur foi aidé à vivre en se fondant
sur leur intime conviction la conviction
de leur âme et de leur esprit cette
tolérance est essentielle pour que les
régions vivent mais elle était mise en
péril de bien des façons
certains musulmans il ya une tendance à
mesurer la fois que l'on à part le degré
de rejet de la foi d'autrui
et pourtant le rejet de la diversité de
faire le tout l'objet de nos efforts au
liban ou ici même en egypte
elle est si nous devons être honnêtes il
faut également travailler au sein même
de l'islam
évitez les divergences entre sunnites et
chiites et leur lutte violente en
particulier en irak la liberté de culte
est essentiel pour la capacité des
peuples à vivre ensemble de demande
toujours voir la manière de les protéger
la liberté de culte par exemple aux
états unis des règles sur la charité ont
fait qu'il était plus difficile pour le
musulman de répondre à leurs obligations
religieuses c'est pour ça que je suis
engagé à travailler avec les musulmans
d'amérique pour nous assurer qu'ils
puissent respecter les préceptes de leur
religion de manière il est important
pour les pays occidentaux d'éviter de
discriminer les musulmans dans la
pratique de la religion par exemple leur
imposant des tenues va sûrement du
vestimentaire on en interdisant d'autres
en fait la foi devrait nous rassembler
et c'est pour cela que nous développons
des projets aux états unis qui rassemble
musulmans juifs et chrétiens ce que nous
avons dit avec le roi abdullah récemment
ou en turquie des liens entre les
peuples le mental actions par exemple
lutter contre la malaria en afrique ou
apporter notre aide après une
catastrophe naturelle sixième point le
sixième point que je voulais soulevé
aujourd'hui le droit des femmes au nom
je sais je sais on peut le dire puisque
au vu de la six ans aujourd'hui qui est
un vrai débat sur la question alors je
rejette la vision de certains
occidentaux selon laquelle une femme qui
choisit de se couvrir les cheveux et
moins égal mais par contre je crois
qu'elle a droit à la même éducation une
question d'égalité
ce n'est pas une coïncidence si les pays
où les femmes sont bien éduqués ont plus
de chance de connaître la prospérité
alors je serai clair la question de
l'égalité des genres ne sont pas
uniquement une question pour l'islam en
turquie au pakistan au bangladesh en
indonésie nous avons vu des pays à
majorité musulmane qui ont choisi une
femme pour leader et pourtant la lutte
pour l'égalité des genres continuent
d'être menées dans bien des aspects de
la vie américaine et dans bien des
aspects du beaucoup de pays du monde
entier
je suis convaincu que nos filles peuvent
participer à aider la société tout
autant que nos fils
notre prospérité conjointe avancera si
nous permettons à l'ensemble de
l'humanité hommes et femmes de donner
leur plein potentiel
je ne crois pas que les femmes de faire
les mêmes choix que les hommes pour être
l'heureux et le régal
je respecte les femmes qui ont décidé de
vivre leur vie de manière traditionnelle
mais ce doit être leur choix et c'est
pour ça que les états unis seront les
partenaires de tous pays à majorité
musulmane qui développeront des
programmes et aileron les filles et les
femmes à se développer à apprendre pour
pouvoir ainsi faire en sorte que chacun
est taxé à ses propres rêves
et pour finir je souhaitais revenir sur
les opportunités de développement
économique
je sais que pour beaucoup la
mondialisation présente des aspects
contradictoires internet et la
télévision peuvent apporter le savoir et
l'information peuvent également être la
source de violences ou d'abus sexuels il
ya donc beaucoup d'opportunités beaucoup
de possibilités mais aussi beaucoup de
risques dans tous les nations y compris
aux états unis
ce changement qu'aucun assistons peut
susciter la crainte la peur que en
raison de la modernité nous perdions un
certain contrôle sur nos choix
économiques sur nos politiques est
encore plus important nos identités
crainte est partagée
la peur de perdre nos traditions nos
familles et deux fois mais je sais
également que le progrès humain ne peut
être ignorée il ne saurait y avoir de
contradiction entre développement et
traditions des pays comme le japon ou la
corée du sud ont bâti leur économie
et qu'ils ont grandi de manière très
forte tout en maintenant leur culture
traditionnelle
on va de même dans beaucoup des pays à
majorité musulmane de kuala lumpur à
dubaï
anciennement et de nos jours les
communautés musulmanes ont été à
l'avant-garde de l'éducation de
l'innovation et c'est là un élément
important parce qu'aucune stratégie de
développement ne serait s'appuyer
uniquement sur ce qui vient de la terre
aucune économie être gérable si les
jeunes sont au chômage
si nous appuyons uniquement par exemple
sur le pétrole nous devons tous
reconnaître que l'éducation l'innovation
seront les monnaies des changes du 21e
siècle devise du 21e siècle et dans de
trop nombreuses communautés musulmanes
ces domaines font l'objet de sous
investissement de même que dans mon pays
nous allons insister sur ces points là
et même si de par le passé les états
unis étaient intéressés dans cette
région du monde par le pétrole et le gaz
nous nous engageons sur l'éducation par
exemple nous allons développer des
programmes de bourses et des changes les
mêmes sources échanges qui ont permis à
mon père de venir en amérique
dans le même temps nous encouragerons
les élèves américains étudient dans les
communautés musulmanes et nous
inciterons les étudiants musulmans à
venir bénéficier de bourses pour
apprendre aux états unis et les enfants
du monde entier de la même manière pour
créer ainsi un vrai réseau mondial de
cette manière un jeune au kansas pour la
communauté que communiquer immédiatement
avec un jeune au caire sur le
développement économique nous allons
bâtir ensemble de volontaires pour
travailler avec les pays musulmans et
nous allons avoir un sommet sur
l'entreprenariat cette année pour
identifier les liens que nous pourrons
créer entre les fondations les
responsables économiques et les
entrepreneurs aux états unis et dans les
communautés musulmanes du monde entier
sur les sciences et la technologie nous
allons lancer à nouveau sans ce fonds
pour soutenir le développement
technologique des pays à majorité
musulmane et transférer ces idées-là sur
les marchés pour pouvoir créer davantage
d'emplois
il ya une excellence scientifique
partout dans le monde et nous allons
insister sur ce point pour collaborer à
des programmes qui développe de
nouvelles sources d'énergie par exemple
créer des emplois verts de l'eau propre
des fichiers numériques faire pousser de
nouvelles cultures travaillons par
exemple avec le monde musulman pour
éradiquer la baule la polio nous allons
accroître les partenariats avec deux
communautés musulmanes pour promouvoir
le soin aux mères et aux enfants
tout ceci doit se faire en partenariat
les américains sont disposés à se
rapprocher des citoyens et des
gouvernements des deux organes
isation des communautés des leaders
religieux et jean l'entreprise musulmane
du monde entier pour aider les gens à
avoir une vie meilleure et les points
que j'ai soulevé aujourd'hui ne seront
pas faciles à appréhender mais nous
avons la responsabilité de nous
rassembler au nom du monde que nous
envisageons un monde où l'extrémisme ne
menacent plus nos peuples et où un monde
où les troupes américaines sont rentrés
à la maison
un monde où les israéliens et les
palestiniens ont leur propre et à chacun
en toute sécurité ou de l'énergie
nucléaire est utilisée à des fins
pacifiques
un monde où les gouvernements servent
leurs citoyens et les droits de tous les
enfants de dieu sont respectées voilà
nos intérêts communs
voilà le monde que nous envisageons mais
nous ne pourrons l'atteindre qu'ensemble
je sais que beaucoup musulmans et non
musulmans se pose la question de savoir
si nous pouvons bâtir ce nouveau départ
ensemble certains ont soif de raviver la
flamme de la division de s'écarter de la
voie du progrès certains suggèrent que
ça ne vaut pas la peine que notre destin
est le désaccord est que les
civilisations sont voués à la
confrontation
beaucoup sont tout simplement sceptiques
quant à la possibilité d'apporter un
vrai changement ya tellement de peur
tellement de méfiance qui s'est bâtie
avec les avec le temps mais si nous
choisissons d'être lié par le passé nous
n'avancerons jamais et je veux dire cela
en particulier aux plus jeunes de toutes
confessions dans tous les pays
plus que quiconque avait la capacité à
réinventer le monde a refaçonné ce monde
nous tous
partageant ce monde sur une période très
courte et la question est de savoir si
nous allons utiliser ce temps pour nous
diviser aussi nous allons profiter pour
nous rassembler développer un effort
conjoint pour trouver un terrain commun
pour nous concentrer sur l'avenir que
nous souhaitons léguer à nos enfants et
pour respecter la dignité de l'ensemble
des êtres humains c'est facile plus
facile de lancer de commencer des
guerres plutôt que d'y mettre fin c'est
plus facile de donner la faute aux
autres que de se remettre en question
soi même c'est plus facile de voir la
différence chez quelqu'un d'autre que de
voir les choses que nous partageons mais
nous devons choisir le bon chemin et pas
simplement le chemin le plus facile
il ya une règle au coeur de tout eh oui
du les religions c'est celle de faire à
autrui ce que nous aimerions qu'ils nous
fassent plutôt ne pas faire rentrer hui
ce qu ils aiment leur baptême ou face
bussereau c'est cette vérité transcende
va au delà des nations et des peuples
ce n'est pas une question de clivage il
n'ya pas noir blanc ou jaune ya pas
musulmans chrétiens ou juifs non il faut
croire en la civilisation et cette
croyance apparaît en corde
j'ai beaucoup beaucoup de monde dans le
monde et c'est la foi en l'autre et
c'est cela qui m'a amené ici aujourd'hui
nous avons le pouvoir de fabriquer le
monde que nous voulons mais à la seule
condition d'avoir le courage de prendre
un nouveau départ en garde en tête ce
qui a été fait et ce qui a été écrit le
coran nous dit que toute l'humanité a
été créé hommes et femmes qui sont
organisés en nation et en tribu pour que
l'on se connaisse les uns les autres
le talmud nous dit que l'ensemble de la
torah vise à la promotion de la paix la
bible nous dit béni soit les faiseurs de
paix car ils seront appelés fils de dieu
les peuples du monde entier peuvent
vivre ensemble dans la paix nous savons
que c'est là la vision de dieu et
maintenant nous nous devons travailler à
cela ici sur terre
merci à tous et que la paix de dieu soit
avec vous